today on the matt wall show the media
said there would be an insurrection in
dc yesterday it never happened
now they're saying the interaction will
actually be another day and the military
has to remain in the city until this new
date are we starting to sense
a pattern here also five headlines
including ebay's ban on the newly
offensive
dr seuss books plus the washington
football team decides to get rid of its
cheerleaders and blm
is revealed to be one big grift what a
shock in our daily cancellation we'll
talk about one democratic
representative's plan
to lower the voting age to 16. is that a
good idea
definitely not we'll talk about all that
and much more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
[Applause]
well the united states capital was on
quote high alert
yesterday the national guard was ready
fencing all in place security perimeters
fortified
the house of representative
representatives canceled its sessions
for the day
this was all done because as the media
constantly reminded us
in the days leading up to yesterday
march 4th uh there was supposed to be
a threat of right-wing terrorist
violence
the right-wing maga domestic terrorists
had threatened to try to overtake the
capitol building on march 4th we were
told
and this was all part of again this is
what we're told all part of some plot
that
as i understand it involved the belief
that march 4th was the true inauguration
day and on that day donald trump would
rise
from the ashes to his rightful throne
and call on his followers to uh
also rise up in vengeance and destroy
his adversaries
now the strange thing is that i never
heard about this conspiracy theory
and this plot from any actual right
wingers i never heard any right winger
talk about this i never saw any right
winger post about this
i don't know of any right wingers who
know of any right wingers who talked
about that or posted about that
this was a far-reaching widely believed
conspiracy theory on the right
that nobody on the right seemed to be
aware of very strange
yet it justified the further military
occupation of dc
and the drama and theatrics of the house
of representatives shutting down in a
panic
and then on march 4th came then march
4th came yesterday and it went
and nothing happened there was you may
have noticed
no attack no insurrection nothing
now this could be because the right-wing
insurrectionists
have invisibility cloaks and actually
did invade the capital but nobody saw
them
and if the terrorists have that kind of
technology then we're definitely in
trouble
i mean we have to admit right but the
other possibility something we should at
least consider is that there was never
any plot at all
that this was all an invention something
that existed only in the fevered
imagination of the left in the media
i mean we certainly can't rule out
either possible i mean the invisibility
cloak thing is
technically possible but but i tend to
think that the latter
is probably the case there was never any
plot
if there were any q anon people who
believe that march 4th was the real
inauguration day or whatever
it was a small smattering of them and
not nearly enough to justify
the continued military occupation of our
nation's capital
so where do we go from here there was
supposed to be right-wing violence on
inauguration day
there was no violence then they said
that there would be the violence on
march 4th and
that didn't happen either the military
occupation of dc is starting to remind
me of the 15 days to slow the spread
thing something with a definitive end
end date originally
but then suddenly becomes ambiguous and
endless
they put a certain measure in place for
a particular reason
then when that reason no longer applies
they find another one
and that's why we can't expect the
military to go home and the fencing to
come down
now that now that another predicted
right-wing insurrection turned out to be
a dud
there are reports today that the united
states capitol police department has
requested an extension
of the national guard presence in the
capitol for another 30 days
or rather 60 days sorry another two
months another two months of the us
capital under military occupation why
for what reason more threats of course
but what threats well you heard about
the threats on inauguration day that
didn't amount to anything
and you heard about the threats on march
4th that didn't amount to anything
now get ready for the next big thing the
next big hype
march 20th you're probably going to be
hearing a lot about march 20th
in the coming days not not from
right-wing insurrectionists or
q anon conspiracy theories but from the
media allegedly reporting what those
other groups are allegedly saying
so here's the here's the newsweek
headline
it says q anon theorists switch date to
march
20th after no after no trump
inauguration
um after no trump inauguration call the
fourth false flag
then the article goes on to talk about
how q anon people branded march 4th a
false flag
and never plan to do anything on that
day which again raises the question as
to why
you know why they canceled the house
session and they stood on high alert
if now the media is telling us that oh
yeah well the me the q anon people said
that
march 4th was never a thing where does
this march
20th date come from well in the newsweek
article you have to go
all the way to the end of that article
and then you find this here's what it
says
some q anon supporters seem to rebrand
the march 4th conspiracy in the wake of
of community suspicion while two
individuals affiliated with the false
theories simply suggested that trump's
inauguration
would take place sometime in the spring
one man identified as ken
told washington post reporter dave
weigel that the former president
will be inaugurated again on march 20th
in comments over the weekend
ken also believes that trump is still in
full command of the military
and biden is acting as president as a
ruse while the pope and others are
rounded up
according to weigel the upcoming date
will mark the 167th anniversary of the
republican party's founding
former members of the whig party are
said to have technically established
the gop during a meeting in ripon
wisconsin on march 20th
1854. oh yes march 20th 1854
the technical founding of the republican
party isn't that a date that all of us
right right-wingers know so well and
care so much about
i talk to conservatives all the time i
said what are you doing for march 20th
big day it's when the whig party
technically formed a republican party
big stuff so that's it um
a guy named ken newsweek is pushing
in its headline a new date for an
insurrection based on something that a
guy named
ken told another guy
that's really it i i'm not
cherry-picking and po
no that that's it in the newsweek
article that's all they got they got a
guy named ken
they don't even explain anything about
ken who is ken
is he from a a forum is he from reddit
is he just like did this washington post
reporter stumble across this guy in a
park bench somewhere
is it his neighbor his uncle his cousin
ah just this is what ken says
this is how journalism works in the
modern age it works namely by
trying to conjure things into reality by
reporting them
as a reality before they are a reality
reality
the game here is completely transparent
the media wants
some kind of violent right-wing
demonstration
and so it is itself inventing conspiracy
theories that it hopes the right will
adopt
and even if the media is ultimately
disappointed and the violence never
materializes
still the threat the entirely invented
threat
is useful enough on its own useful to
guys like congressman jamal
bowman who was on msnbc recently
explaining why
the city has to remain fortified even
after all this here's what he says
what do you feel or how do you feel
about the decision to extend the
security perimeter
and the presence of the national guard
at the capitol
it's something we have to do
unfortunately because the
threat of white nationalists and and and
white supremacists is real
you know they are continuing to organize
and galvanize
across this country uh there are many
examples of them infiltrating
uh law enforcement across this country
so we have to make sure the capital is
protected and our
elected officials are protected but we
also have to be proactive
you know we cannot take the threat of
white nationalism
lightly you know over the last several
years
they've made their presence uh felt
whether it's the um
the tree of life synagogue shooting the
christ church
uh shooting which happened overseas as
well as the
ame church shooting and then obviously
the january
6 insurrection uh we have to do
everything we can to protect ourselves
and protect the capital
but we also have to be proactive in
dealing with the issue of white
nationalism
in a very serious way did you catch that
we have to do everything we can to
protect ourselves
a politician saying that the government
has to do everything it can to protect
him sure i mean he's asking to be
protected from a
non-existent threat even so talk about
saying the quiet part out loud
do everything you can to protect me
no in fact jamal um the government
should not do everything it can to
protect
you not at all there's a whole lot it
can do
that it shouldn't do it's doing some of
those things right now yes
the government can fortify the nation's
capital and permanently militarize it
to protect politicians to protect itself
but it shouldn't
but this is how bowman and his democrat
cohorts see it
do everything to protect him and almost
nothing to protect regular american
citizens his constituents
from violent blm riding in our cities or
from the ordinary everyday violence and
bloodshed that wreaks havoc
in those same cities but look
none of this means that our elected
representatives lack courage i don't
want you to think that it would be
unfair of me not to make
note of democratic representative al
green
who did demonstrate unparalleled courage
and heroism yesterday in the midst of
the attack by invisible or possibly
non-existent insurrectionist
here's the hill uh with that report
representative al green is sending a
message to qnon and right-wing extremist
threats
by sitting on the capitol steps on
thursday the day authorities warn
militia groups were potentially planning
another breach of the building
he told the hill quote i want to make a
statement to let people know
those who have threatened those of us
who cherish this freedom that we have
here that we refuse to allow those
threats to negate our freedom
capitol police and the fbi have
cautioned that militia groups that took
part in the deadly insurrection
at the capitol on january 6 when a group
of trump supporters attempted to disrupt
the certification
of the electoral college votes had
drafted plans for a second attack on
march 4th
wow wow the bravery
he is sitting on the steps behind a
barbed wire fence
patrolled by armed national guardsmen
and staring down a crowd that consists
of media members and a handful of
pedestrians who happen to
be walking by um truly the world has
never seen courage
such as this for this man to sit in what
is right now the safest place on earth
in spite of the alleged threats of a
handful of nutty troll accounts on the
internet
well i for one am stunned stunned
sure it takes more courage to simply
walk down the street in chicago a lot
more actually
than to do what he did but still let's
not focus on
any of that let's focus on him which is
what he wants us to do
very inspiring very courageous and on
that positive note
let's move on now to our five headlines
you know i have to say i i really hate
you know that i don't like complaining
uh it's the last thing in the world that
i want to do is complain i especially
don't like to complain about
um here where i work it's a little
awkward to do but there are times when
i feel i have no other choice so you
know i uh i'm in this studio here
as you can see this beautiful studio and
this is also where i work during the day
i just sit here all day working
and it's pretty dark in this in this
studio all we have are the studio lights
which work for the camera but in reality
it's like really dim and dark in here so
for months i've just been sitting in the
studio in the darkness
all day and until yesterday i was
informed after like three months
that hidden behind one of the props back
here is a is a light switch
that will turn on lights in the whole
studio
i've been here for three months and i
just found out that there are lights in
the studio that i can turn on
nobody told me everyone else knew but no
one told me so every person that i've
asked about this and i've said i
you know i didn't know that there were
lights i could turn on every single
person told me well
we thought you liked just sitting in the
dark
and then i thought about and i realized
okay that's fair i can see why you would
assume that about me so maybe
maybe this is my fault but i take no
responsibility
is it my fault that i never thought to
check on the wall for a light switch
after three months
no i refuse to take that responsibility
okay number one uh from the daily wire
it says internet auction site
ebay confirmed thursday that it is
scouring its open auctions for six
canceled dr seuss titles reviewing
seller profiles and removing the
listings which the site claims violate
its offensive materials policy
on thursday morning the daily wire
reported that ebay sellers who had
listed copies of six dr seuss titles
marked as
racist and offensive um and removed them
from publication by dr seuss enterprises
those are again these are the the banned
blacklisted titles so if you have these
you know make sure they're under lock
and key um
if the cops show up to your house asking
if you have the you know make sure you
have them
stored somewhere um i don't know if
they're gonna start serving
search warrants looking for this but uh
the the titles are and to think that i
saw it on mulberry street
if i ran the zoo mcelligott's pool which
i've never even heard of that one
i consider myself a seuss expert but
i've never heard of that one before on
beyond zebra scrambled egg super
and the cat's quizzer so anyone on ebay
who had been
selling those titles
um now they're not allowed to sell them
they've been removed from ebay too
now this this it's really easy to take
issues like this as the left has been
doing the media has been doing
and it reducing it down
and pretending that it's all about dr
seuss
every time there's a canceled culture
type story what the media wants to do
say
what do you care about dr seuss so much
what's the big deal with dr seuss
whoever it is if it's gina caranos well
it's just gina carano it's just this one
person
okay but first of all that doesn't make
it right even if it is just the one
person but the second thing is
it's not just the one person this is
part of a trend a very troubling trend
that's the point that's what we're
concerned about
it's not only about dr seuss as big a
fan as i am
of his literature it's about what it
represents
and what it represents here is that
you know on on this this past monday
you you could buy dr seuss books on ebay
uh it was it was no problem dr seuss was
simply dr seuss
then it was decided all at once
by the left and the media and the powers
the cultural powers that be
that this stuff is all offensive
and within a couple of days you can't
even sell the stuff on ebay anymore
you can't even sell it secondhand
that's the troubling trend
where things can happen this suddenly
and in such a sort of coordinated
way yeah you should be troubled by that
no matter how you feel about dr seuss
because as i've been pointing out all
along and i think it's a
it's an important thing to point out
these books that are now banned on ebay
and have been we've decided they're
offensive they've been in publication
for like 80 years
and nobody had a problem so why
now why all of a sudden why all at once
do these things have to happen
all right number two this is from espn
says the washington football team has
discontinued its cheerleader program
after more than 50 years
replacing it with a coed dance squad as
part of its rebranding effort
the team had announced last month that
the cheerleader program was paused while
it decided what direction the rebranding
would take
um and now i'm not going to read this
whole thing
but they're getting rid of and replacing
with what a dance squad so this is this
is an example of um
you know this is classic example of
corporate woke virtue signaling
where it they're not really doing
anything
what's the difference between a
cheerleader squad and a co-ed dance
squad
cheerleader squads already have dudes on
them in most these cases
like those are the guys that are tossing
the cheerleaders in the air
and already what they do is dance right
so what is it's a distinction without a
difference
but you know throwing another bone to
the left that's what this is about
corporate virtue signaling
and it's it's the nfl um continuing
in in in little this is little and
bigger ways
uh continuing to try to appease and
appeal to
people who are not fans anyway and will
never be
number three from the daily wires as
president uh since president joe biden
took office in january the department of
justice has been quietly dismissing
federal cases against portland uh
portland oregon rioters according to
local media
kgw reported wednesday federal
prosecutors have dismissed more than
one-third of cases stemming from last
summer's
violent protests in downtown portland
when protesters clashed with federal
agents
the network reviewed federal court
records and found 31 of the 90 protest
cases
have been dismissed by the u.s
department of justice including a mix of
misdemeanor and felony charges
some of the most serious charges dropped
include four defendants charged with
assaulting a federal officer which is a
felony
more than half of the drop charges were
dismissed with prejudice which
several former federal prosecutors
described as extremely rare dismissal
prejudice means the case can't be
brought back to court
the charges all stem from confrontations
between quote anti-fascist protesters
and special agent federal government
brought in to protect and defend the
city's federal courthouse over the
summer so
these are people some of them charge
felony charges of assaulting a federal
officer
in the process of trying to damage
at a minimum damage or take over a
federal courthouse
and those charges are being dropped and
yet we still
hear this absolute nonsense that somehow
uh the the rioters at the capitol are
getting the
kid glove treatment while the blm and
antifa rioters had
you know the full force of of of the
federal government come down on them
it is exactly the opposite is the case
this is another thing with the left in
the media they they
we are we are looking at something with
our own eyes
and they're telling us that that thing
doesn't exist don't believe your own
lying eyes
there can't be any good reason
especially if you care about
maintaining order if you're worried
about insurrections and all these things
what could be the good reason to drop
charges on people who assaulted federal
officers who were defending a federal
court building
meanwhile and i think we have this clip
um
you know there in in some cases the
people that
went into the capitol building on
january 6 are facing 20 years they're
trying to put 20 gears on some of these
people
like for example the infamous q anon
shaman
who's this obviously this wacky nutty
guy who he was the guy with the weird uh
you know headdress thing that he was
wearing and um
he was in you know one of the people in
the capitol
uh they're trying to put 20 years on
this guy
just to get an idea of who this guy is
and what his intentions were
while he was interviewed by cbs
yesterday
and here's what he said my actions on
january 6 how would i describe them
well i sang a song and that's a part of
shamanism
it's about creating positive vibrations
in a sacred chamber
i also stopped people from stealing and
vandalizing that sacred space the senate
okay i actually stopped somebody from
stealing muffins out of the out of the
break room
i also said a prayer in that sacred
chamber because it was my intention
to bring divinity and to bring god back
into the senate
but jake legally you were not allowed to
be in what you're calling the sacred
chamber and that is and that is the one
very serious regret that i have was
believing that when we were waived in by
police officers
that it was acceptable okay so he's
uh in the capitol building
saying a prayer trying to bring good
vibrations
and then we find out some other some
some of the other dastardly criminals in
there
uh somebody was trying to steal muffins
from the break room
i wonder if they could put 20 years on
that guy is that guy going to get the
muffin thief
is he going to get 20 years for that
quite possibly now obviously
we all agree that they shouldn't have
been in there it's illegal to be in
there
trespassing and everything um
but you hear that guy does that sound
like a dangerous
right-wing terrorist is that guy a
threat to overturn
democracy was he going to overturn the
results of the election was that guy
you worried that that guy could have
done that
it is hard for me to see how that guy
is any more of a threat than for example
the uh blm or zantiva people who
assaulted federal officers in in
uh important and are now having their
charges dropped explain to me how that
guy the shaman guy with his good
vibrations and prayers and trying to
guard the uh
the sacred muffins of the break room how
is he a greater threat
than the people assaulting federal
officers or the people that burn down
and invaded the uh
police station in minneapolis or the
people who you know burned down
uh
apartment buildings and stores and cvs's
and and
drug stores and liquor stores we don't
care about any of that right
i mean those are just the places where
average americans live and work
who cares about that
you have a tough time explaining to me
how that dude is a bigger threat
was ever at any point a greater threat
than how about the blm rioters who
um assaulted a woman in new york with
two by force
beat her over the head with him caught
on video
who are you more worried about who would
you be more worried about
who would you feel more uncomfortable
with walking down
you know the street
come across a rider who beat a woman
with a 2x4 or
that dude who do you think is a greater
threat to you
all right number four jen saki um
does this thing now where she answers
questions i guess from twitter
and she was asked about how biden will
will unify the country we've all
wondered this right because we've heard
this plan democrats are going to
unify the country um what is his plan to
do it
and she laid out the plan let's listen
what is president biden doing to create
unity in our country this is what the
president
ran on and what he's focused on every
day it's about
his actions every day uh his rhetoric
and how we all speak from this
government
he doesn't look at people or hear their
stories
based on their political party or what
their registration is
he's really in this job because he wants
to help all americans and govern for all
americans hopefully
that action and that kind of leadership
will help unify the country
okay so that's it that's how he's going
to do it um i did take notes so he's
going to unify the country through his
actions
through his rhetoric and how we all
speak from this government
okay so there's no plan basically he's
he's of course there's he's not gonna
he has no plan at all to do any kind of
unifying whatsoever that's that's what
we learned from that
could there be any could there be that
is the most
vague answer i think i've ever heard
um from a politician or spokesperson
you're they think about it she the
question is how is he going to do this
thing that he said he's going to say
he's gonna unify what's his plan
and her answer is well through his
actions his actions will do it
now really his plan to do this is to
take actions
um and he'll he'll also be saying things
too so
really his plan is to say some things
and do some things
that's the plan yeah but what is he
going to say and do
it doesn't matter things things that's
what he's going to say and do
all right number five this is from the
daily mail says michael brown senior
is among the black lives matter
activists demanding 20 million dollars
from the black lives matter global
network foundation after its finances
were disclosed for the first time
revealing the group raked in 90 million
dollars in donations last year
the non-profit shared its the the
non-profit
um shared its financial snapshot with
the associated press amid accusations
from local chapters that they are not
being given any of the money
brown whose son michael brown jr was
killed by police in ferguson in 2014
says he and his advocacy group
have been shortchanged by the larger blm
organization
uh brown asked in a statement why hasn't
my family's foundation received any
assistance from the movement
who are they giving it to and what are
they doing with it
um and this is this is uh
there have been there have been several
reports in recent days about
local as as mentioned in the daily mail
report local blm chapters that are upset
you know maybe having a little bit of an
awakening moment
maybe where they realize oh this is all
this is all a giant scam that i'm a part
of
that's all this is 90 million dollars
what what yes it's obviously a scam
but i i do not have any sympathy for you
if you got basically robbed by blm
because you
you're you're one of the morons who
contributed to that 90 million dollars
in donations what do you think they're
going to do with it
what do you think their plan is
like what what in your in in
in your best estimation what did you
think they were going to do
it's obviously uh a scam
and if you have money to donate that's
great so many better
give give to an organization that helps
you know children
i mean if you really want to give to an
organization that uh defends
the idea that black lives matter give to
a pro-life organization
trying to defend black lives in the womb
and white lives in all lives
so no big surprise there giant giant
scam uh finally here's a bonus this is a
new york post report that's um
talking about this new uh uh apparently
a new new phenomenon now
where men well it's not that new but
more and more men are wearing makeup now
because of uh
because all our lives have have migrated
to zoom
and so it says when realtor ben dixon
caught sight of his face during an early
morning zoom call with a client in
january
he was distracted by what he perceived
were bags and discoloration
under his eyes i thought you could do
with a little help here the 42 year old
admitted to the post
noting how he'd become more bothered by
his appearance while working remotely
during the pandemic so like a growing
number of dudes
who are increasingly horrified by their
appearances on countless zoom calls
he consulted a friend with seemingly
perfect skin who generously shared his
secret
concealer for men more men than ever
are now buying makeup resulting in the
male side of the industry experiencing a
leap in sales partly due
to the work from home trend now
i had this really this kind of
existential crisis moment because
i saw this report being shared on
twitter about how more and more guys are
wearing makeup
and at first i wanted to share it and
kind of laugh and say
guys wearing makeup you know kind of
make fun of them
but then i realized that i wear makeup
every day
because really when you're on camp but
here's the thing it's different one
number one it's different when i do it
okay general principle
uh number two when you're on camera
that's the one exception i will make if
you don't
and i resisted the makeup thing for a
long time with but if you're on camera
you don't wear makeup
you will look like a corpse i still look
like one with the makeup imagine if i
didn't have it
so i'm gonna make an allowance here
at least for myself if nobody else all
right let's move on now to reading
the youtube comments um
let's see this is from nanny manley
says my comment is totally unrelated to
today's show but i wanted to share a
funny dream
i had matt and his wife were over at my
house having dinner with me and my
family
i did not consent to you having a dream
about me and my wife by the way
this is a non-consensual dream that i'm
a part of
as the dinner went on someone made a
joke and when alyssa started to laugh
her face turned into the laughing emoji
matt unceremoniously canceled her on the
spot
when i woke up and remembered the dream
i started laughing then thought how
funny it would be if my face turned into
a laughing emoji too
i need more sleep yes you do
um first of all it sounds horrifying
second i have a general policy where i i
think i've been clear about this i all
dream stories are terrible
and boring and they're only interesting
to the person who is relaying them
so you're banned for the show for that
sometimes i can make an exception if i'm
in the dream
like okay i'll listen to it but no
exception here
um freak of fitness says who else has
pondered about moving out into the woods
of an extreme remote location smash all
of our technology and live off the land
a naked and afraid alone collaboration
but instead i'll be clothed not afraid
and i'd have my family with me
uh in in all uh seriousness i
i think that is something we should
think about i think about that every day
there's no there's no good reason not to
do it
um i think all of our lives will be
better
i think it's a weird situation for me
because i make my living on the internet
but i'm absolutely certain that the
internet has been a net negative for
mankind
and you who are watching this right now
you would all be way better off
if you didn't if you didn't spend any
time on the internet at all and so much
of
so much else of modern technology maybe
you don't need to forsake all modern
technology
but if you dr if we all drastically
decreased our consumption
and use of modern technology we will be
way happier as people
the internet is not making us happy at
all
so that's that is my honest belief
that's how i urge people like if you can
spend less time on the internet do it
but at the same time if you do spend
less time on the internet then we lose
money so
there's a conflict of interest there um
and finally
secret caucasian man says matt would you
rather be a ninja or a pirate i gotta
say the comment's kind of lacking today
but of course i'd rather be a ninja you
know every day we have to talk about
companies that are uh you know censoring
conservatives banning conservatives
shutting down speech all these
hopelessly woke leftist companies of
course we have to talk about them
because they're a big problem in society
today
but it's nice to also be able to talk
about the companies that hold the same
values and beliefs as us
and are working with us and for us in
the culture and one of those would be 40
days for life
you know the state of our culture
frustrates all of us you know
politicians
lobbying for radical pro-abortion
legislation infanticide
um and but where i see the real progress
is on the grassroots level in
on the community the most localized
level and that's what 40 days for life
is all about 40 days for life
went from one peaceful prayer vigil in
front of a planned parenthood in texas
to now a thousand cities
66 countries 40 days of prayer fasting
and law abiding vigils have saved 18 000
and three babies
from abortion they've helped the 211
abortion workers leave their job and
have closed 107
abortion facilities so these this is a
group that is
saving lives 18 000 lives that they've
saved
be a part of the beginning of the end of
abortion by joining one million
volunteers and sign up for your location
at 40daysforlife.com you can also stay
updated on the number one pro-life
podcast
40 days for life the largest spring
campaign ever is happening from february
17th to march 28th
you want to get on board and be a part
of that don't wait for washington to
heal our culture go to work
in our neighborhood at 40daysforlife.com
and you know there are so many crazy
leftist theories and ideas in some cases
outright lies
uh in many cases outright lies floating
around out there
and uh we spent a lot of time on the
daily wire trying to deal with that
well ben shapiro's new show debunked is
all about that every friday ben exposes
popular fallacies purported by
leftist activists and politicians with
short mini documentaries
that entertain and keep you informed on
fact versus fiction when it comes to hot
button issues
which let's face it everything's a hot
but [ __ ] button issue these days
the last one the first one in fact was
about minimum wage um
and next ben shapiro is taking on the
subject of unions
couldn't be a better time with all the
craziness from the teachers unions
to talk about that so debunked is now
available to daily wire members
exclusively not a member yet go to
dailywire.com
subscribe and use code debunked to get
25 off your new memberships and stay
tuned for this friday's episode which
again
will be all about breaking down unions
um go sign up code debunked
25 off and now let's get to our daily
cancellation
so today we're going to cancel the most
underrated member of the squad ayanna
presley uh i call her underrated because
she's easily the craziest one of the
bunch even more so than aoc or ilhan
omar
yet she doesn't always get the credit
that her craziness deserves
demonstrating my point here she is on
the house floor yesterday
introducing an amendment to lower the
voting age to 16. here's what she says
to immigration reform to climate change
to the future of work and minimum wage
our young people are organizing
mobilizing and calling us to action
they are at the forefront of social
movements and have more than earned
inclusion in our democracy
mr speaker 16 and 17 year olds
constituents of mine are supporting
their families
they are working not for enrichment or
to build a resume but because they have
no choice
they are attending school full time and
taking care of loved ones in the midst
of the covered crisis
young people are contributing both to
the labor force and their local
economies
by paying taxes and yet they are
deprived of the opportunity to exercise
their right to vote
some have questioned the maturity of our
youth i don't
16 and 17 year olds today possess wisdom
and maturity
defined by today's challenges hardships
and opportunities
they deserve and demand a government
that is accountable to them
a government that values their voices
and understands the depth and breadth of
their lived experience
there it is lived experience everyone
take a shot
yes we must understand the depth of a 16
year old's lived experience
they're people of great wisdom she says
great maturity
their voices should be heard in our
democratic process they should have a
say
and all of these claims would be really
super convincing to me
if it weren't for the fact that i was a
16 year old once
and if i had never met any other 16 year
olds then maybe i could find this rosy
picture
believable but my experience both with
being 16 and being around 16 year olds
tells me that no
they are not wise and mature they are by
and large idiots
and i say that with no malice or
judgment i was the biggest idiot of them
all at 16.
i very often marvel at the fact that i
managed to live through the experience
of being 16.
at 16 especially if you're a guy you
will literally
risk your life just to amuse your
friends
like just getting a wow dude that was
awesome out of your buddies is enough
justification to do something that has a
75 percent chance of killing you
that's the kind of wisdom that a 16 year
old has okay
it's not nearly the kind of wisdom that
i have now as a 34 year old man
when i would never do anything that has
a 75 chance of killing me just to make
people laugh
it would have to have to be no more than
a 50 chance
there's also science behind this you
know your anecdotal experience
with teenagers and being a teenager is
backed by science
it's not a coincidence that we all have
this impression of teenagers
as impetuous impulsive hormonal
half-sane barbarians
science tells us that the prefrontal
cortex the region of our brain
that controls things like logical
reasoning discernment impulse control
all the things that we would normally
relate to wisdom
isn't fully developed until the age of
25.
so if you like me look back at yourself
from the age of like
15 to 24 and think my
god who was that person that person was
actually insane i was an actual lunatic
well this is why your executive brain
functions your capacity to be a
reasonable and mature adult
were not fully online
now you might object and say well by
this logic instead of lowering the
voting age we should raise it to 25 is
that what you're saying
yes exactly that's precisely what i'm
saying
precisely what we should be doing the
country would not by any measure benefit
from having 16 year olds vote ayana
presley would benefit
because her ideas and policies are so
stupid and destructive that most 16 year
olds
would find them appealing but the
country would not benefit
it also doesn't benefit from having 18
year olds vote
there is simply no downside to requiring
people to grow a little older
become a little wiser accumulate some
more lived experience before they vote
what's the worst that could come from
such a policy what's the worst case
scenario
a bunch of kids get their feelings hurt
storm off to their rooms
you won't let me vote well i hate you
i mean that might happen i can think of
plenty of downside to allowing
uninformed and unwise people to vote
we've been living through that downside
for decades
now with all that said
i would be willing to consider a
compromise here
in in an intelligent objection to the
points i've raised so far
is that sure most 16 year olds
are immature and stupid but then again a
lot of 36 year olds are too
there are many 56 year olds who are as
ill-equipped for the voting booth as the
average 16 year old if not more so
that's all true so my compromise would
be this similar to what i proposed in
the past
all voters must take a simple test
measuring their basic aptitude and how
informed they are
we'll be setting a pretty low bar with
the test starting small
questions like who is the secretary of
state what does the legislative branch
of the government do
okay stuff like that i say all voters be
required to take this test
any who pass can vote any who fail
cannot so if you're 16 and you pass fine
if you're 62 and you fail you're out
now i'd like to see voting requirements
that go far beyond this i think the
requirements
should be strict enough that millions of
current voters are ruled out i like to
see the numbers reduced by about 70 to
80 percent
that's what i think we should shoot for
i don't think voting should be a big
party that everybody is invited to i
think it should be a
something that only the most informed
most engaged most productive and mature
americans have the privilege to
participate in
i realize this idea is upsetting to a
lot of people but i don't care
and anyway i'm willing to compromise i'm
willing to lower the bar
so that all you have to do is pass a
test that any eighth grader
should be able to pass anyone who does
pass it votes
anyone who doesn't doesn't so what do
you say iona presley
can we strike a deal no we can't can we
because you want the uninformed to vote
you want people who are utterly clueless
to file into the polling stations
and drown out the votes of the informed
and the engaged
citizens that's the whole reason
why you're proposing this change that's
also the reason
along with a bunch of other reasons why
you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin